This episode is sponsored by Newport Healthcare, providing results-driven mental health treatment for teens and young adults ages 12 to 28 who are struggling with trauma, depression, anxiety, and co-occurring issues like eating disorders and substance abuse. Newport's integrated programs incorporate evidence-based experiential activities such as art therapy alongside trauma-informed clinical modalities. Learn more at Newport Healthcare.com. It's a modern art cliche. A museum visitor stands in front of an abstract painting of colorful shapes and lines and shaking her head says, my four-year-old could do that. Art is universal. There has never been a human society without some type of visual, musical, or other art form, but we don't always agree on what makes good art, or for that matter, what makes something art at all. Philosophers have long tried to answer those questions, and more recently, psychologists have waited. in as well, applying scientific research methods to try to understand why people make art, how we experience it, and how it affects us.
本期节目由Newport Healthcare赞助，他们为12至28岁正与创伤、抑郁、焦虑以及饮食失调和药物滥用等共病问题作斗争的青少年和年轻人提供以结果为导向的心理健康治疗。Newport的综合项目将艺术治疗等循证体验式活动与创伤知情临床模式相结合。欲了解更多信息，请访问Newport Healthcare.com。这是一个现代艺术的陈词滥调。一位博物馆参观者站在一幅色彩斑斓的形状和线条组成的抽象画前，摇着头说：“我四岁的孩子也能画出这个。”艺术是普遍存在的。人类社会从未有过没有某种视觉、音乐或其他艺术形式的时期，但我们并不总是对什么才算好艺术，或者说，什么才算艺术达成共识。哲学家们长期以来一直试图回答这些问题，而最近，心理学家也参与进来，应用科学研究方法试图理解人们为什么创作艺术，我们如何体验艺术，以及它如何影响我们。
So what does make something art? What makes something good art? Is it true that your kid could do that, or can a lay person tell the difference between a child's painting and an abstract masterpiece? Why do forgeries bother us so much? Why do we even care if a painting is an original or a skillful copy? Does artistic talent have to be inborn or can it be developed through years of hard work? Why do we have such strong emotional responses to art?
那么，究竟是什么让某样东西成为艺术？又是什么让它成为好的艺术？你的孩子真的能画出那种作品吗？或者说，外行能分辨出儿童画和抽象杰作的区别吗？为什么赝品会让我们如此困扰？为什么我们甚至会在意一幅画是原作还是精巧的复制品？艺术天赋是天生的，还是可以通过多年的刻苦努力培养出来的？为什么我们对艺术会有如此强烈的情感反应？
And what is the purpose of arts education? And how should art be taught in school? How can psychology help us answer all these questions? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Ellen Winner, a professor emerita of psychology at Boston College, and Senior Research Associate at Project Zero at the Harvard Graduate School of Education.
艺术教育的目的是什么？在学校里应该如何教授艺术？心理学如何帮助我们回答所有这些问题？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是Kim Mills。我们今天的嘉宾是波士顿学院心理学荣休教授、哈佛大学教育研究生院“零点项目”高级研究员Ellen Winner博士。
Dr. Winner has spent decades studying the psychology of art and the impact of arts education. She has written more than 200 articles and authored or co-authored seven books, including her two most recent, How Art Works, a psychological exploration, and an uneasy guest in the schoolhouse, art education from colonial times to a promising future. She has also served as president of APA's Society for the Psychology of Aesthetics, Creativity, and Arts, and as a fellow of APA and of the International Association of Empirical Aesthetics. Thank you for joining me, Dr. Winnu. Thank you so much for having me, Kim. Let's start with the big question. What is art and why is it so hard to come up with a definition for it? And how can psychology help us to think about
Winner博士花费数十年研究艺术心理学和艺术教育的影响。她撰写了200多篇文章，并著有或合著了七本书，包括她最近的两部作品：《艺术是如何运作的：心理学探索》和《校舍里的不安之客：从殖民时代到充满希望的未来的艺术教育》。她还曾担任美国心理学会（APA）审美、创造力和艺术心理学分会主席，并担任APA和国际经验美学协会的会士。感谢您参加我的节目，Winner博士。非常感谢您的邀请，Kim。让我们从那个宏大的问题开始。什么是艺术？为什么给它下定义如此困难？心理学又如何帮助我们思考
what makes something art? Well, that is, of course, the big question. Some people think that you can't be a psychologist of art unless you have a definition of art, but philosophers have argued over the centuries about how to define art, and there has been no agreement. Every time somebody has put forward a definition of a set of necessary and sufficient features that would make something art, people come up with counter examples. If you say it has to be beautiful, people will give you ugly art.
什么让某样东西成为艺术？嗯，这当然是一个宏大的问题。有些人认为，除非你对艺术有定义，否则你不能成为艺术心理学家，但哲学家们几个世纪以来一直在争论如何定义艺术，并且一直没有达成共识。每当有人提出一套使某样东西成为艺术的必要和充分特征的定义时，人们总能提出反例。如果你说它必须是美的，人们就会给你看丑陋的艺术。
If you say it has to be intentional, people will give you a splattered paint blob that some people frame and put on their walls. So I think that the reason that art is so difficult to define is because artists are always pushing the boundaries and trying to make things, make art that people never would have before thought of as art, such as a hunk of metal, of scrap metal. or a pile of trash, conceptual art, a chair in the middle of a room, who would have thought those would be considered art in the 19th century? And in fact, in the 19th century, people couldn't accept the impressionists as art. They thought it was hideous, and they said it's not art. So it's because artists are always messing with our concept of art by trying to push the boundaries.
如果你说它必须是有意图的，人们就会给你看一团泼溅的油漆，有些人会把它装裱起来挂在墙上。所以我认为，艺术之所以难以定义，是因为艺术家们总是在不断突破界限，试图创作出人们以前从未想过是艺术的东西，比如一块金属废料，或者一堆垃圾，概念艺术，房间中间的一把椅子，谁会想到这些在19世纪会被认为是艺术呢？事实上，在19世纪，人们无法接受印象派作品是艺术。他们认为那很丑陋，并说那不是艺术。所以，这是因为艺术家们总是通过试图突破界限来扰乱我们对艺术的概念。
And that's why some philosophers, and I agree with them, say art is an open concept. It's ever expanding. And we can talk about what's typical in art, what are the characteristic features of prototypical works of art. But we will never be able to come up with a set of necessary and sufficient features that tell us this is art, this is not art. which also in some ways explains why, for example, people didn't like the impressionists at first, and now we think that they were brilliant. So the concept of how we accept art changes over time. I mean, people rioted when they heard Stravinsky's Firebird suite the first time, and yet today, it's a loved piece of music. It's not as if the art changes, it's people's conception somehow changes.
这就是为什么一些哲学家——我也同意他们的观点——说艺术是一个开放的概念。它在不断扩展。我们可以谈论艺术中什么是典型的，什么是原型艺术作品的特征。但我们永远无法得出一套必要且充分的特征来告诉我们：这是艺术，这不是艺术。这也从某种程度上解释了为什么，例如，人们起初不喜欢印象派，而现在我们认为他们是天才。所以我们接受艺术的概念会随着时间而改变。我的意思是，当人们第一次听到斯特拉文斯基的《火鸟》组曲时，他们甚至发生了骚乱，但今天，它是一部备受喜爱的音乐作品。并不是艺术本身变了，而是人们的观念在某种程度上发生了改变。
Absolutely. Art, our evaluation of works of art change over the centuries. Some work were reviled, and now are loved, and the opposite as well. So that speaks to the question of whether we are simply influenced by what's in vogue. And some psychologists have argued that we only like what's familiar. And once we got familiar with the impressionists, we started to think they were great. And certainly we are influenced by the gatekeepers of art, the people who decide what goes into museums and what goes into art history textbooks. And there is a big argument about whether we're just influenced by what's in vogue or whether we really can see what's great in art.
绝对是这样。艺术，我们对艺术作品的评价在几个世纪以来发生了变化。有些作品曾经被唾弃，现在却备受喜爱，反之亦然。这引出了一个问题：我们是否仅仅受到流行趋势的影响？一些心理学家认为，我们只喜欢熟悉的东西。一旦我们熟悉了印象派，我们就开始认为他们很伟大。当然，我们受到艺术把关人的影响，即那些决定什么进入博物馆、什么进入艺术史教科书的人。关于我们是仅仅受到流行趋势的影响，还是我们真的能看出艺术中的伟大之处，存在着巨大的争论。
And we can see what's objectively great in art. So there's a big argument about whether our aesthetic opinions of what is good and bad art is based on objectively provable claims or whether it's just a subjective opinion like I like vanilla and you like chocolate ice cream. So going back to that person in the museum looking at, for example, a Jackson Pollock painting and saying, my kid could do that. Is that person right? You've done research that's tried to answer that question empirically. What have you found? Well, we've done a series of studies looking at whether ordinary people who claim to have no particular knowledge about abstract art, whether they can tell the difference between works by four. four-year-olds and works by famous artists, abstract expressionist artists like Jackson Pollock or
我们可以看出艺术中客观上伟大的东西。因此，关于我们对好坏艺术的审美观点是基于客观可证明的主张，还是仅仅像“我喜欢香草冰淇淋，你喜欢巧克力冰淇淋”那样的主观意见，存在着巨大的争论。回到博物馆里看着例如杰克逊·波洛克画作并说“我孩子也能画出那个”的人身上。那个人对吗？你做过试图从经验上回答这个问题的研究。你发现了什么？嗯，我们进行了一系列研究，观察那些声称对抽象艺术没有特别了解的普通人，是否能分辨出四岁儿童的作品和著名艺术家（如杰克逊·波洛克或
Sy Twombly or Mark Rothko. And we also have thrown into this jumble works by animals. Elephants, monkeys, and chimpanzees have been given paint brushes, either in the wild, elephants in the wild, kind of captured in the wild, or apes and monkeys in cages. And they have made abstract art. And the question is, is it true that there is no distinction that we can make? And we've shown in a whole series of studies that people, ordinary people, not art experts, but just ordinary people who don't know that much about abstract art, are significantly above chance. When you show them a pair of images, one by a famous artist and one by a child or an animal, unlabeled, they are significantly above chance in choosing the better work of art,
赛·托姆布雷或马克·罗斯科）的抽象表现主义作品之间的区别。我们还在这个混杂中加入了动物的作品。大象、猴子和黑猩猩被给予了画笔，无论是野外的大象，还是笼子里的猿猴。它们创作了抽象艺术。问题是，我们真的无法做出区分吗？我们在这一系列研究中表明，普通人——不是艺术专家，只是对抽象艺术了解不多的普通人——在分辨时显著高于随机水平。当你给他们看一对图像，一张由著名艺术家创作，一张由儿童或动物创作，且不贴标签时，他们在选择更好的艺术作品时，显著高于随机水平，
the one they like better, the one they think is more intentional, the one they think is more structured. Those are always the actual artist. That doesn't mean they're 100% correct. And the more they think it's unintentional, like a work by sigh Twombly often looks like just an unintentional scribble, the more they think something, a work by a famous artist is unintentional, the more likely they are to confuse it with that of a child or an animal. So we're not 100%, but we are statistically, significantly above chance in our ability to distinguish this body of work by famous artists from ones that look superficially similar. We've done the study in a whole number of ways, and it always comes out the same. So people are wrong when they say
即他们更喜欢的那一幅，他们认为更有意图的那一幅，他们认为结构更严谨的那一幅。那些总是真正的艺术家作品。这并不意味着他们100%正确。他们越认为它是无意图的——比如赛·托姆布雷的作品看起来往往就像无意图的涂鸦——他们越认为某件著名艺术家的作品是无意图的，他们就越有可能将其与儿童或动物的作品混淆。所以我们不是100%正确，但在区分著名艺术家的作品与表面上相似的作品的能力上，我们在统计学上显著高于随机水平。我们以多种方式进行了这项研究，结果总是相同的。所以人们说“我孩子也能画出那个”时是错误的，
my kid could have done that. And they actually know more about abstract art than they think they do. And it's important to hear that the studies have been replicated, which is sometimes a challenge in psychology. That's right. Psychology has had a replication crisis, but we've done about six studies on this using different methodologies, and it keeps coming out the same. So people often think that children's drawings are just a less competent, messier version of adult art, but you argue that kids approach making art in an entirely different way from adults. Can you talk about that and what can we learn about the way children drawing paint? Well, for a long time, people thought of children's art as just error-prone and something that needed to be corrected. And traditional art education teaches children as quickly as possible how to draw like adults or how to draw realistically. This is how you draw a head. This is how you draw a person.
而且他们对抽象艺术的了解实际上比他们自己认为的要多。重要的是要听到这些研究已经被重复验证过，这在心理学中有时是一个挑战。没错。心理学经历过“重复危机”，但我们对此进行了大约六项研究，使用了不同的方法，结果始终如一。所以人们经常认为儿童画只是成人艺术的一种能力较差、更凌乱的版本，但你认为孩子们接触艺术创作的方式与成人完全不同。你能谈谈这一点，以及我们能从儿童绘画和涂鸦的方式中学到什么吗？嗯，很长一段时间以来，人们认为儿童艺术只是容易出错，需要纠正的东西。传统的艺术教育尽可能快地教孩子们如何像成年人一样绘画，或者如何写实地绘画。这是你画头的方法。这是你画人的方法。
But with the progressive era in the beginning of the 20th century, with progressive education came progressive art education. And there came the view that the child is an artist in his. her own right. And we should look at the kinds of things that children do which look like, quote-unquote, errors. But they're really children's solutions to how to solve the very difficult problem of taking the three-dimensional world and mapping it on a small piece of two-dimensional paper. And so children, what we have to realize is that children are not striving to be realists. They're not trying to draw realistically. They're trying to create a readable representation. so that when you look at it, you will see a person, too, if they've drawn a person.
但在20世纪初的进步主义时代，随着进步主义教育的出现，进步主义艺术教育也随之而来。人们开始认为孩子本身就是艺术家。我们应该审视孩子们所做的那些看起来像是“错误”的事情。但它们实际上是孩子们解决如何将三维世界映射到一张小小的二维纸上这一极其困难问题的解决方案。所以孩子们，我们必须意识到，孩子们并不是在努力成为现实主义者。他们不是在试图写实地绘画。他们是在试图创造一种可读的表征，这样当你看着它时，如果他们画的是一个人，你也能看出是一个人。
And they're striving for the simplest possible graphic equivalent of a person. Rudolf Arnheim, great psychologist of art, really stated this in the most clear way that I've come across, that children are seeking the simplest possible structural equivalent on a page. And they don't care if the sun is purple. They don't care if a person has arms coming out of his or her head. I mean, a tadpole, children often draw tadpoles. pole, what we call a tadpole for their first drawings. It's a circle and their arms coming out of the circle for the arms. Sorry, their lines coming out of the circle for the arms and the legs. If you say to
他们正在努力寻找一个人最简单的图形等价物。鲁道夫·阿恩海姆，伟大的艺术心理学家，确实以我所见过的最清晰的方式阐述了这一点，即孩子们正在纸上寻找最简单的结构等价物。他们不在乎太阳是否是紫色的。他们不在乎一个人是否长着从头上伸出来的手臂。我的意思是，蝌蚪，孩子们经常画蝌蚪。我们称之为蝌蚪，这是他们最初的画作。那是一个圆圈，手臂和腿是从圆圈里伸出来的线条。如果你对
children, where do arms come from? And they ask you to look at, you ask them to look at them. They'll say they come from the shoulders. Well, why do you draw them coming out of the head? Because I like to do it that way. Because they're not striving for realism. And so another really interesting thing that Rudolph Arnheim pointed out is that a lot of the quote-unquote errors that children make can be seen in works of art by famous artists. For instance, showing multiple perspectives, showing there's a famous drawing of that Arnheim published of two children playing chess, and you see their side views, but the chess board is shown standing up straight so that you could see the entire chess board. And Arnheim found the equivalent of that in a medieval painting. So why,
孩子们说，手臂是从哪里长出来的？你让他们看一看，你让他们看自己。他们会说它们是从肩膀长出来的。嗯，那你为什么画它们从头上长出来？因为我喜欢那样画。因为他们不是在追求写实。所以鲁道夫·阿恩海姆指出的另一件非常有趣的事情是，孩子们犯的许多所谓的“错误”可以在著名艺术家的作品中看到。例如，展示多个视角，有一个著名的阿恩海姆发表的两个孩子下棋的画，你看到的是他们的侧面视图，但棋盘被展示为直立的，这样你就可以看到整个棋盘。阿恩海姆在中世纪的一幅画中发现了与之等同的东西。所以为什么，
Why do artists do this? Because it's a way of showing the clearest view of each thing they're drawing. The clearest way to show it's a chess board is to stand it up. But the clearest view to show two people sitting at a table is to draw them in profile. Children are not bothered by mixed perspectives. And of course, if you look at cubists in the 20th century, that's exactly what they sought. So there are many ways to draw. And realism is just one way to put the three-dimensional world on paper.
为什么艺术家要这样做？因为这是一种展示他们所画的每样东西最清晰视图的方法。展示棋盘最清晰的方法是把它立起来。但展示两个人坐在桌子旁最清晰的视图是画他们的侧面轮廓。孩子们不会被混合视角所困扰。当然，如果你看看20世纪的立体派，那正是他们所追求的。所以绘画有很多种方式。而写实只是将三维世界呈现在纸上的一种方式。
So what about child prodigies? What do child art prodigies do differently from other children? And what's the difference between a prodigy and someone who's just talented? Well, with my former student, now colleague Jen Drake, who's at Brooklyn College, we have been studying art prodigies for quite a while. And we have a website now with art prodigies works featured on them. And almost all of them start out drawing. in a very different way than I just described. They start out drawing very realistically. If you look at a three-year-old's drawing of a person,
那么神童呢？艺术神童与其他孩子有什么不同？神童和仅仅有天赋的人之间有什么区别？嗯，我和我以前的学生、现在的同事Jen Drake（她在布鲁克林学院）一直在研究艺术神童。我们现在有一个网站，上面展示了艺术神童的作品。他们几乎所有人开始绘画时，
a typical three-year-old, you'll see something like that tadpole I described. Just one circle with lines emanating from it and maybe two eyes and a smile. We have three-year-old's drawings of people that are highly differentiated. There's a head, there's a body, their legs, their arms, there's fingers, there's eyelashes.
方式都与我刚才描述的非常不同。他们开始时画得非常写实。如果你看一个三岁孩子的画，
They're not perfectly realistic, but there's certainly a long way away from the tagpole towards the realistic spectrum. And we call them precocious realists. There are some, however, who start out abstractly. And you can actually find them on the web. Their parents are marketing them as abstract expressionist prodigies. And when I looked at those, I said to Jen, you know, I think these are just typical three-year-old drawings of abstract drawings.
一个典型的三岁孩子，你会看到像我描述的那种蝌蚪。只有一个圆圈，线条从中散发出来，可能还有两只眼睛和一个微笑。我们有三岁孩子画的人像，它们高度分化。有头，有身体，有腿，有手臂，有手指，有睫毛。
They're charming, they're beautiful. I love child art, but these are not gifted. Well, Jen took the abstract art prodigies, quote-unquote prodigies work, and she paired it with typical preschoolers work and with works by famous abstract artists. And the interesting thing she found is that people actually can tell the difference between the abstract art prodigies work and the typical children's abstract work, showing that maybe these kids really are gifted. They're just gifted in a different way from our precocious realists.
它们并不完全写实，但肯定离蝌蚪很远，向写实光谱靠拢。我们称他们为早熟的现实主义者。然而，有些人一开始是抽象的。你实际上可以在网上找到他们。他们的父母把他们包装成抽象表现主义神童。当我看到那些作品时，我对Jen说，你知道，我认为这些只是典型的三岁孩子的抽象画。
So there may be two roots to giftedness. You also asked, what's the difference between giftedness and talent? And I would say, you can use either word. I don't care. They're the same to me. The question is the degree, the degree of talent or the degree of giftedness. And a prodigy is extreme. They're kids that are less gifted but are still somewhat slightly above their age in how they draw.
它们很迷人，很漂亮。我喜欢儿童艺术，但这些并不算有天赋。嗯，Jen拿走了这些所谓的“抽象艺术神童”的作品，并将其与典型的学龄前儿童的作品以及著名抽象艺术家的作品进行了配对。她发现有趣的是，人们实际上可以分辨出抽象艺术神童的作品和典型儿童的抽象作品，这表明这些孩子可能确实有天赋。他们只是在天赋上与我们的早熟现实主义者不同。
In terms of what happens to these prodigies when they grow up, Well, that's another question we could talk about. Do child prodigies tend to be kind of obsessive, like they get up in the morning and they want to draw? And when they come home from school, they want to draw more and you've got to tear them away? I coined a phrase when I wrote my book, Gifted Children, Myths and Realities. I wrote about academically gifted children as well as musically and artistically gifted. And I said they had a rage to master. And people told me not to use that word because they said it sounded like anger.
所以天赋可能有两个根源。你还问了，天赋和才华有什么区别？我会说，你可以使用任何一个词。我不在乎。对我来说它们是一样的。问题是程度，才华的程度或天赋的程度。而神童是极端的。有些孩子天赋较少，但在绘画方面仍然比同龄人稍微超前一点。
But I stuck to it. And for some reason, this term has caught on, and I keep bumping into it in places. And parents tell me that's exactly what they see. They can't stop their kids from doing what they're doing. So we had one kid who, the minute he woke up, he asked for his crayons and paper. He drew during breakfast. And he drew during kindergarten. His teacher didn't like that.
至于这些神童长大后会怎样，嗯，那是我们可以讨论的另一个问题。艺术神童是否往往有点强迫症，比如他们早上起床就想画画？当他们放学回家时，他们想画更多，你必须把他们拉开？我在写《天才儿童：神话与现实》一书时创造了一个短语。我写了关于学术天才儿童以及音乐和艺术天才儿童的内容。我说他们有一种“掌握的狂热”。人们告诉我不要使用那个词，因为他们说听起来像愤怒。
I guess she wasn't a very progressive teacher, but she tried to get him to stop. I've had parents say they have to force their kids to stop to go out and play and get some fresh share. We had the same kid who used to wake up and ask for his drawings and his paper and crayons used to invite kids home after school. And then it turns out he just wanted to draw them. He wanted them to pose for him. So these kids often have social issues because they're so different from other kids. But yes, they are obsessed with their area of high ability. And this is true with kids who are academically gifted as well or musically gifted or sports gifted. Well, let's move away from kids for the moment and talk about art and emotions.
我想她可能不是一位很前卫的老师，但她确实试图让他停下来。我曾听家长说，他们不得不强迫孩子停下来去户外玩耍，呼吸新鲜空气。我们遇到过同样的孩子，他过去常常醒来就要求画画、要纸和蜡笔，还邀请同学放学后去他家。结果发现，他只是想画他们。他想让他们为他当模特。所以这些孩子往往有社交问题，因为他们与同龄人太不一样了。但确实，他们沉迷于自己擅长的领域。对于在学术、音乐或体育方面有天赋的孩子来说，情况也是如此。好吧，我们暂时离开孩子的话题，谈谈艺术和情感。
There are some forms of art that really move people deeply. And I ask this because some people can listen to a piece of music or read a novel and be moved to tears, but you don't go to an art museum and see people standing in front of paintings weeping. What is happening in our brains that makes us react differently to different media? Some people actually do claim that they cry in front of paintings, And there is a book by James Elkins called Pictures and Tears. But I think it's much, much rarer than crying at music. One thing is that music has words often, and I think often people are crying at the sad lyrics.
有些艺术形式确实能深深打动人。我之所以这样问，是因为有些人听一段音乐或读一部小说会感动落泪，但你走进美术馆，却看不到人们站在画作前哭泣。我们的大脑发生了什么，导致我们对不同的媒介有不同的反应？有些人确实声称他们在画作前哭了，詹姆斯·埃尔金斯（James Elkins）有一本书叫《图片与眼泪》（Pictures and Tears）。但我认为这比听音乐流泪要罕见得多。其中一个原因是音乐通常有歌词，我认为人们往往是被悲伤的歌词感动哭了。
And I also think that if you see people in concerts and they say they're moved to tears, they may be moved to tears, but they're not actually weeping. But I do think, and this is really a speculative, on my part. It hasn't really been thoroughly tested. That people experience greater emotions when they listen to music than when they walk through an art museum. And I think this is because the, first of all, music mimics the sound of the human voice. At least some instruments do. And that is very powerful emotionally, a violin or a cello. Well, a cello is too low, but a violin particularly. And that is very powerful.
我也认为，如果你看到人们在音乐会上说他们感动落泪，他们可能确实被感动了，但并没有真正痛哭流涕。但我确实认为——这纯属我个人的推测，还没有经过彻底的验证——人们在听音乐时比在美术馆漫步时体验到的情感更强烈。我认为这是因为，首先，音乐模仿了人类的声音。至少有些乐器是这样。这在情感上非常有力量，比如小提琴或大提琴。好吧，大提琴音调太低了，但小提琴尤其如此。这非常有感染力。
High voices are happy, low voices are sad, very loud voices can also be anxious, sudden noises can be anxious. So that's one reason. Another reason is that when people listen to music, they sit for a long time and they're enveloped in the music because the music takes place over time. When people go to an art museum, they just walk right by pictures really quickly. and they're often with somebody else and they're chatting away. So the real test would be to put somebody in front of an emotional painting, like Mark Rothko's paintings, because Mark Rothko said he was painting pure emotion. Put them in front of it alone, maybe in a darkened room where all they can see is the lit-up painting
高音是快乐的，低音是悲伤的，非常响亮的声音也可能让人焦虑，突如其来的噪音也会让人焦虑。所以这是一个原因。另一个原因是，当人们听音乐时，他们会坐很长时间，沉浸在音乐中，因为音乐是在时间中展开的。当人们去美术馆时，他们只是很快地走过画作，而且通常是和别人在一起，聊个不停。所以真正的测试应该是把一个人放在一幅富有情感的画作前，比如马克·罗斯科（Mark Rothko）的画，因为罗斯科说他在画纯粹的情感。让他们独自待在画作前，也许是在一个昏暗的房间里，只能看到那幅被照亮的画作，
and have them talk about their emotions over 20 minutes. And I think if you did that, you would get much more emotional responses to visual art. maybe not as much as to music, but I just, when you listen to music and you have lyrics, you're not just moved by the music, you're also moved by the words. When you look at visual art that's representational, you're also moved by the content. So if you see somebody weeping at the death of their child,
让他们在20分钟内谈论自己的感受。我认为如果你这样做，你会得到对视觉艺术更强烈的情感反应。也许不如对音乐的反应那么强烈，但我只是觉得，当你听有歌词的音乐时，你不仅被音乐感动，还被歌词感动。当你观看具象的视觉艺术时，你也会被内容所感动。所以如果你看到有人为孩子的离世而哭泣，
that's very emotional, but you can't separate the content from the fact that it's, art. And so therefore, I think the best test is to take music without lyrics and abstract art and look at which one causes a more emotional reaction. And I think it will be the music. Is that something you're planning to test? I hope that Jen Drake tested. And we did test it informally. I tested it in my seminar of psychology and art over the years. And each time I did it, people said they had, I asked them to come in and give me their three most powerful feelings when listening to music without lyrics and with looking at abstract art.
那是非常感人的，但你无法将内容与它是艺术这一事实分离开来。因此，我认为最好的测试是选取没有歌词的音乐和抽象艺术，看看哪一种能引起更强烈的情感反应。我认为会是音乐。这是你计划测试的内容吗？我希望珍·德雷克（Jen Drake）测试过。我们确实进行过非正式的测试。多年来，我在我的心理学与艺术研讨会上测试过。每次我这样做，我都要求他们进来，说出他们在听无歌词音乐和看抽象艺术时最强烈的三个感受。
They all came in for the music and talked about sad, nostalgia, joy. For the abstract art, they often said puzzled, confused, irritated, annoyed, because they didn't know how to look at it. But nobody came in and said and mentioned a powerful emotion from abstract art. These are kids that didn't know much about abstract art. And again, they hadn't been put in the circumstances that I'm describing, which would be the ideal way to test it. There are people that have gone to the Mark Rothgo Chapel and left sentences in the guest book as they were leaving, saying that they were moved to tears. But I think that's multi-determined.
他们听音乐时都提到了悲伤、怀旧、快乐。对于抽象艺术，他们常说感到困惑、迷茫、烦躁、恼火，因为他们不知道该怎么看。但没有人进来提到从抽象艺术中获得了强烈的情感。这些孩子对抽象艺术了解不多。同样，他们也没有被置于我所描述的那种理想的测试环境中。有些人去过马克·罗斯科教堂，离开时在留言簿上写下句子，说他们感动得流下了眼泪。但我认为那是多种因素共同作用的结果。
You're in a chapel. You're surrounded only by Mark Rothgow, and you're sitting for quite a while. And then people do feel very emotional. And now we're going to take a short break. This episode is sponsored by Newport Healthcare, offering sustainable healing for teens and young adults struggling with mental health issues and co-occurring disorders, including depression, anxiety, and substance abuse. Newport offers a full continuum of care at locations across the country to young people ages 12 to 28, with tailored treatment plans that include creative
你身处教堂，周围只有马克·罗斯科的作品，而且你坐了很长一段时间。人们确实会感到非常激动。现在我们要休息一下。本期节目由纽波特医疗保健（Newport Healthcare）赞助，为在心理健康问题和共病（包括抑郁、焦虑和药物滥用）中挣扎的青少年和年轻人提供可持续的康复服务。纽波特在全国各地为12至28岁的年轻人提供全方位的护理，并制定量身定制的治疗计划，其中包括创造性
therapies like art and music to tap into the healing power. of self-expression. Learn more at newporthealthcare.com. Now, you've done some interesting research on the question of authenticity and why we care about whether a painting is an original or a copy. It's not just about the monetary value either. You've found that people actually like a painting more if they're told it's an artist's original rather than an exact copy made by an assistant. Yes. So why does originality matter so much to us? Well, you described the study exactly. write, we asked people in different conditions, how much do you like this work? We asked them a whole
疗法，如艺术和音乐，以挖掘自我表达的治愈力量。详情请访问 newporthealthcare.com。现在，你对真实性问题以及为什么我们关心一幅画是原作还是复制品做了一些有趣的研究。这不仅仅是关于金钱价值。你发现，如果人们被告知一幅画是艺术家的原作，而不是助手制作的精确复制品，他们实际上会更喜欢它。是的。那么为什么原创性对我们如此重要？嗯，你准确地描述了这项研究。我们让人们在不同的条件下评估：你有多喜欢这件作品？我们问了他们一整套
range of evaluative questions. And in one case, we told them that it was the original, the first work in a series of 10 identical paintings by artist X, and it was worth X amount on the market. In another case, we said this is the identical painting, and it was done by the artist's assistant, and this is not an immoral thing. This is something that is done in the art world all the time, and it is worth the exact same thing on the market, and it has the artist's signature on it even. And then in another case, we said this is done by a very clever forger, and it's worth much less on the market. So when people are shown something that they're told as a forgery, they don't like it. Okay. So we know that already, because there are lots of studies showing that if you tell people to forgery,
评估性问题。在一种情况下，我们告诉他们这是原作，是艺术家X创作的10幅相同画作中的第一幅，在市场上价值X金额。在另一种情况下，我们说这是完全相同的画作，是由艺术家的助手完成的，这并不是什么不道德的事情。这是艺术界经常做的事情，它在市场上的价值完全一样，甚至还有艺术家的签名。然后在另一种情况下，我们说这是由一位非常聪明的伪造者完成的，在市场上价值要低得多。所以当人们看到被告知是伪造品的东西时，他们不喜欢它。好的。所以我们已经知道了，因为有很多研究表明，如果你告诉人们这是伪造品，
they value it less. So for us, the key question was the comparison between the people that thought it was the first in a series and was done by the artist and the people that thought it was the second in a series done by the artist's assistant worth the same amount on the art market both signed by the artist both identical and people still valued the one by the artist better and since we'd taken away monetary value and since we had taken away immorality by saying that it was nothing immoral about it and we actually asked people to assess how moral or immoral it was for the assistant to do this. And then we factored that into our statistical analysis. So we, quote, unquote, controlled for that.
他们对它的评价就会降低。所以对我们来说，关键问题在于比较：认为它是系列中的第一幅且由艺术家本人完成的人，与认为它是系列中的第二幅且由艺术家助手完成的人。两者在艺术市场上价值相同，都有艺术家签名，且完全相同。但人们仍然认为艺术家本人创作的那幅更好。既然我们已经排除了金钱价值，也通过说明这没有什么不道德的而排除了道德因素——我们甚至要求人们评估助手这样做在道德上是否妥当，并将此纳入了我们的统计分析中。所以我们，所谓的，控制了这些变量。
So even when we got rid of morality and monetary value, people still wanted the one by the artist more. And our argument is that what's left is simply knowing that it was touched by the hand and the mind of the artist. and that there's something here which psychologists like to call essentialism, that the painting by the artist has something of the artist's essence in it. And this is a mystical, magical belief. And if you push people, they would say, well, I know it's not really there, but that's really the way I feel. There's something special about knowing that Leonardo's hand actually touched this canvas,
所以即使我们排除了道德和金钱价值，人们仍然更想要艺术家本人创作的那一幅。我们的论点是，剩下的唯一因素就是知道它曾被艺术家的手和思想触碰过。这里存在一种心理学家喜欢称之为“本质主义”的东西，即艺术家创作的画作中包含了一些艺术家的本质。这是一种神秘的、魔幻的信念。如果你追问人们，他们会说，好吧，我知道它并不真的在那里，但这确实是我的感觉。知道达芬奇的手真的触碰过这块画布，
or this actually came out of Leonardo's mind. So I think it comes down to thinking that you're reading the traces of the artist's mind. when you look at the work. And we're not interested in the traces of a copier's mind because the mind is less interesting. And we feel that way about a lot of things. I think there's the example of you lose your wedding ring and you go out and buy an exact copy of the wedding ring and you wear it, but it's never the same thing because it's not the one you got on the day of your marriage. Exactly. You can see essentialism everywhere in special objects. Yeah, right. So special objects. Let's say a work is deemed a masterpiece. Let's talk about the Mona Lisa, for example. Now, if Rembrandt had painted two of them
或者这确实出自达芬奇的思想，这感觉很特别。所以我认为归根结底，当你观看作品时，你觉得自己在阅读艺术家思想的痕迹。我们对复制者的思想痕迹不感兴趣，因为那个思想没那么有趣。我们对很多事情都有这种感觉。我想起你弄丢了结婚戒指，然后去买了一个一模一样的戒指戴上，但这永远不一样，因为它不是你结婚那天收到的那一个。没错。你可以在特殊物品中随处看到本质主义。是的，没错。所以，特殊物品。假设一件作品被视为杰作。我们以《蒙娜丽莎》为例。现在，如果伦勃朗画了两幅
exactly alike, would we see them do you think as equally valuable and beautiful? And if not, why not? Are they equally valued? You could argue that they wouldn't be because we like scarcity. And if you look at prints, they are where you have an artist who makes an etching and then you have like 100 numbered prints. And then you have unnumbered prints. The numbered prints are more valuable than the unnumbered, but prints are always less valuable than the painting. And it may well be because there's many of them.
一模一样的画，你认为我们会觉得它们同样有价值和美丽吗？如果不是，为什么？它们的价值相等吗？你可以争辩说它们不会相等，因为我们喜欢稀缺性。如果你看版画，艺术家制作了一块蚀刻版，然后印出100张编号的印刷品。然后还有未编号的印刷品。编号的印刷品比未编号的更有价值，但印刷品总是比画作价值低。这很可能是因为它们数量很多。
And with a painting, you only have one. And I think if you had two identical Mona Lisa's, you would say, which one is the real one or which one is the one that was painted first? And actually, there is some evidence that people like the thing that was made first by the artist if they were two identical things. Even if the second one is better. Well, I'm talking about two identical things.
而对于画作，你只有一幅。我认为如果你有两幅一模一样的《蒙娜丽莎》，你会问，哪一幅是真的，或者哪一幅是先画出来的？事实上，有一些证据表明，如果两件东西完全相同，人们更喜欢艺术家先制作的那一件。即使第二件更好。嗯，我指的是两件完全相同的东西。
If an artist makes two identical things, people like the one that was made first. And there is some empirical evidence for this, and it had to do with a album on a Beatles record, if you remember what a record is. And I don't remember the details, but I do remember that when people were told this was the first one made,
如果艺术家制作了两件完全相同的东西，人们喜欢先制作的那一件。这有一些实证证据，它与披头士唱片的一张专辑有关，如果你还记得什么是唱片的话。我不记得细节了，但我确实记得当人们被告知这是第一张制作出来的唱片时，
they valued it more. when it was the later one made. People are superstitious, mystical, even very rational people. Yes. So we recently had another psychologist on this podcast, Paul Bloom, who talked about why people choose to suffer. Yes. So why do we seem to like to do things that cause us emotional or even physical pain?
他们对它的评价更高。当它是后来制作的时候。人们是迷信的、神秘的，即使是非常理性的人也是如此。是的。所以我们最近在播客上请了另一位心理学家保罗·布鲁姆（Paul Bloom），他谈到了为什么人们选择受苦。是的。那么为什么我们似乎喜欢做那些会给我们带来情感甚至身体痛苦的事情呢？
And one aspect of that is that people often want to look at artwork or listen to music that makes them sad? What's your take on that? Why do we seek out art that makes us sad? Or horrified or disgusted or angry, yes. That is a big puzzle. But I think we have a little bit of take on this. We seek out works of art that make us feel negative emotions
其中一个方面是，人们经常想看那些让他们感到悲伤的艺术作品或听悲伤的音乐？你对此有何看法？为什么我们要寻找那些让我们感到悲伤的艺术？或者感到恐惧、厌恶或愤怒，是的。这是一个巨大的谜题。但我认为我们对此有一点见解。我们寻找那些让我们产生负面情绪的艺术作品，
when we would run away from situations in our real life that would make us feel those same emotions. So, for example, we may look at Goya's painting of a firing squad. And this is a very famous painting, and we look at it and admire it and are very moved by it. But if we were actually seeing a real firing squad, many of us would turn away because we couldn't bear it. and if it was somebody we knew in the firing squad, we would be screaming our head off. So one argument is that when we're looking at something that we know is art, it's fiction. It's not happening to us.
而在现实生活中，我们会逃避那些会让我们产生同样情绪的情况。例如，我们可能会看戈雅（Goya）的《1808年5月3日的枪杀》（The Third of May 1808）。这是一幅非常著名的画，我们看着它，欣赏它，并被它深深打动。但如果我们真的看到一场真实的枪决，我们许多人会转过头去，因为我们无法忍受。如果枪决现场有我们认识的人，我们会尖叫起来。所以一个论点是，当我们看我们知道是艺术的东西时，它是虚构的。它并没有发生在我们身上。
So we don't have to do anything about it. And therefore, it's safe. We can feel these feelings of sorrow, for example, without feeling that we have to go deal with this and fix it and keep it in our life forever. We're choosing it. It's not inflict. I think Paul Blum talks about chosen suffering and unchosen suffering. Unchosen is much worse. We choose to look at these works of art and we're in control and we know we can turn away and we know it's just art so it's safe. And there are two really important things to say about this. One is Winfrey Menninghouse in Germany has shown that when people look at art that elicit's negative
所以我们不必对此采取任何行动。因此，它是安全的。我们可以感受到这些悲伤的情绪，而不必觉得我们必须去处理它、解决它并永远背负着它。我们是主动选择它的。这不是强加的。我想保罗·布鲁姆谈到了“选择性受苦”和“非选择性受苦”。非选择性的要糟糕得多。我们选择观看这些艺术作品，我们处于掌控之中，我们知道我们可以转过身去，我们知道这只是艺术，所以它是安全的。关于这一点，有两件非常重要的事情要说。一是德国的温弗里德·门宁豪斯（Winfried Menninghaus）已经证明，当人们观看能引发负面
emotions, not only is it more attention-grabbing, but it's also very moving. And moving is a feeling that's mixed with positive and negative emotions. And the feeling of being moved is actually very pleasurable. So when we look at negative art, we do feel negative emotions, but we also feel positive emotions mixed in, perhaps because of the beauty of the art, but also, and this is the second point I wanted to make, because of the meaning we make of it. Meaning making is is pleasurable and feels good and is something that we want to do. And we may think about the firing squad in Boya or Picasso's Guernica and think about war and injustice. We may also savor the negative feelings. And this is what it's like to feel horror. This is what it's
情绪的艺术时，它不仅更吸引注意力，而且非常感人。而“感动”是一种混合了积极和消极情绪的感觉。被感动的感觉实际上是非常愉悦的。所以当我们看负面艺术时，我们确实感受到了负面情绪，但我们也感受到了混合其中的积极情绪，这可能是因为艺术的美感，但也因为——这是我想说的第二点——我们从中赋予了意义。赋予意义是愉悦的，感觉很好，是我们想要做的事情。我们可能会思考戈雅的枪决画作或毕加索的《格尔尼卡》，并思考战争和不公正。我们也可以细细品味这些负面情绪。这就是感受恐惧的感觉。这就是
like to feel grief without having to feel it in our own personal lives. So we can savor it, we can think about it. So art makes us think, negative art makes us think, and it moves us and gives us a mixture of positive and negative feelings. And the last thing I'll say to that is I think that the greatest art and the greatest novels and the greatest species of music are often things that are very sad or tragic. If you think of Shakespeare's works, we love the tragedies. Many people think they're greater than the comedies. So your most recent book is about arts education.
感受悲伤的感觉，而不必在我们的个人生活中去经历它。所以我们可以品味它，我们可以思考它。所以艺术让我们思考，负面艺术让我们思考，它打动我们，给我们带来积极和消极情绪的混合体。最后我要说的是，我认为最伟大的艺术、最伟大的小说和最伟大的音乐作品往往是非常悲伤或悲剧性的。如果你想到莎士比亚的作品，我们热爱悲剧。许多人认为它们比喜剧更伟大。所以你最近的一本书是关于艺术教育的。
And there's been a lot of debate over the years about whether art and music education can boost achievement in other areas. For example, does learning to play a musical instrument boost kids' math scores? And you argue that there's really not much evidence for that, but that arts education is valuable for its own sake. Can you talk about that? What's the intrinsic value of arts education? How do we know that it's really not improving us in other areas? Okay. Well, this was work I did with Lois Hetland, colleague of mine, and this was done quite a while ago, 20 years ago, was our first foray into that, we were skeptical about the claim that art education makes kids do better in school, because what that really means is art education
多年来，关于艺术和音乐教育是否能促进其他领域的成就，一直存在很多争论。例如，学习演奏乐器能提高孩子的数学成绩吗？你认为这方面的证据并不多，但艺术教育本身就很有价值。你能谈谈这个吗？艺术教育的内在价值是什么？我们怎么知道它真的没有在其他领域改善我们？好的。嗯，这是我和我的同事洛伊斯·赫特兰（Lois Hetland）一起做的工作，这是很久以前做的，20年前，是我们第一次涉足这个领域。我们对“艺术教育能让孩子在学校表现更好”的说法持怀疑态度，因为那实际上意味着艺术教育
improves kids' math and verbal ability, and we weren't sure what the mechanism for that would be. So we did what's called a meta-analysis, where we compiled studies by other people and grouped like-minded studies together, so studies that were only about visual arts or only about music, and have the same kind of outcomes, test scores, verbal scores, math scores, and we conducted a large statistical study on this body of works as if it was one big study. And what we found over and over again is there was a correlation between art education and doing well in school. The correlational studies showed, yes, kids who take a lot of art actually do better in school. But when you look at the experimental studies that tried to look at causality
提高孩子的数学和语言能力，但我们不确定其背后的机制是什么。因此，我们进行了一项所谓的“元分析”，即汇集他人的研究，并将志同道合的研究归类在一起，比如只关注视觉艺术或只关注音乐的研究，且具有相同的成果，如考试成绩、语言成绩、数学成绩。我们对这些研究成果进行了一项大型统计研究，就好像它是一项大型研究一样。我们反复发现，艺术教育与学校表现良好之间存在相关性。相关性研究表明，是的，参加大量艺术活动的孩子在学校的表现确实更好。但是，当你审视那些试图研究因果关系的实验性研究时
by taking kids and randomly assigning them to art education or non-art education and looking at improvement over a year, there was nothing. So we came out with a paper called Mute Those Claims, no evidence yet for transfer. And transfer of learning from one area to another has been notoriously hard to prove in psychology. People used to think that learning Latin made you more logical. Well, that's been shown not to be right. Learning Latin makes you better at Latin.
通过将孩子随机分配到艺术教育组或非艺术教育组，并观察一年内的进步，结果却什么也没有发现。因此，我们发表了一篇名为《让这些主张静音：尚无证据支持迁移》的论文。在心理学中，学习从一个领域迁移到另一个领域一直被公认为很难证明。人们过去认为学习拉丁语会让你更具逻辑性。好吧，这已被证明是不正确的。学习拉丁语只会让你更擅长拉丁语。
So people were very angry at us for coming out with these findings. They said, you shouldn't have published this because this is what we need to keep the arts in school. And we said we're trying to change the conversation because as soon as a smart superintendent finds out that it's not true, he'll say, well, then let's get rid of the arts. Or he might say, or she might say, if what we're doing this for is to improve test scores, let's just have direct test score prep because that's obviously going to be more effective than indirect training. So we were really reviled for a while. We were told that we were going to ruin quality arts education for the kids in this country. We decided we should do something positive. So we said, well, let's look at what the arts do teach.
所以人们对我们得出这些发现感到非常愤怒。他们说，你不应该发表这篇文章，因为这是我们保持学校艺术课程所需要的。我们说，我们试图改变这种对话，因为一旦聪明的学监发现这不是真的，他就会说，好吧，那我们就取消艺术课程吧。或者他可能会说，如果我们要这样做是为了提高考试成绩，那我们直接进行考试准备就好了，因为那显然比间接训练更有效。所以我们确实被诋毁了一段时间。我们被告知，我们将毁掉这个国家孩子们的优质艺术教育。我们决定应该做一些积极的事情。所以我们说，好吧，让我们看看艺术到底教了什么。
And so we did a big ethnographic study of visual arts learning in two high schools. And we filmed, we interviewed, and in the end, we did a qualitative study where we came out with habits that we saw a number of very important, big, broad habits of mind being taught in these classes. We didn't measure learning. That would come later. We measured teaching. And we argued that the real benefit of visual arts education is that kids are learning to do very important things that are not going to translate into test scores. They're learning to look carefully. They're learning to reflect on their own works and process and evaluate it. A very important skill. They're learning in critiques to accept criticism and change their works accordingly. They're learning to express
于是，我们对两所高中的视觉艺术学习进行了一项大型民族志研究。我们进行了拍摄、采访，最后进行了一项定性研究，总结出了我们在这些课堂上观察到的许多非常重要、宏大且广泛的思维习惯。我们没有测量学习成果，那是以后的事。我们测量的是教学。我们认为，视觉艺术教育的真正好处在于，孩子们正在学习做一些非常重要的事情，这些事情不会转化为考试成绩。他们正在学习仔细观察。他们正在学习反思自己的作品和过程并进行评估。这是一项非常重要的技能。他们在评论中学习接受批评并相应地修改作品。他们正在学习表达
personal meanings in their work. So observation, expression, reflection, engagement. They're learning to be very engaged, to stick to things over time. These are big, broad habits of mind, which we think are very important to have. They can be taught in any subject, but we think they're often best talk in art classrooms with a studio atmosphere and with critiques. And so we had a book, we wrote a book called Studio Thinking, The Real Benefits of Visual Arts Education, and we're now coming out with our third edition. And we also wrote one called Studio Thinking from the start,
作品中的个人意义。所以观察、表达、反思、参与。他们正在学习如何全身心投入，如何长期坚持。这些都是宏大、广泛的思维习惯，我们认为这些习惯非常重要。它们可以在任何学科中教授，但我们认为它们通常在具有工作室氛围和评论环节的艺术课堂中教授效果最好。因此，我们写了一本书，名为《工作室思维：视觉艺术教育的真正好处》，我们现在正在推出第三版。我们还写了一本名为《从一开始的艺术思维》，
which is about how teachers have taken this and translated it into very young kids' art education. So I think that the real benefits of arts education are teaching. teaching kids to think like artists, and it has nothing to do with how well they're going to do on their SATs. And it shouldn't. Art shouldn't have to justify itself in terms of something else. We don't ask math to justify itself in terms of art, for example. Right, right. So what about adults? Does experiencing art, like listening to music or reading novels or looking at great paintings make us any smarter or more insightful or more empathetic? Do we know? Actually, I've just been involved in a series of studies on art and empathy, but we've been looking not at visual art, though one could. I've been looking at narrative art, both in stories and in film. To do a study like this, what you need to do is take a group of people and assign them randomly to a story and to a nonfiction or a non-narrative form with the same content. And then measure there, we've been looking at empathy, measure there. their attitudes about something before and after.
这本书讲述了教师们如何将其应用并转化为幼儿的艺术教育。所以我认为艺术教育的真正好处是教学。教孩子们像艺术家一样思考，这与他们在SAT考试中表现如何毫无关系。也不应该有关系。艺术不应该为了证明自己的价值而依赖于其他事物。例如，我们不会要求数学为了证明自己的价值而依赖于艺术。对，对。那么成年人呢？体验艺术，比如听音乐、读小说或欣赏伟大的画作，会让我们变得更聪明、更有洞察力或更有同理心吗？我们知道吗？事实上，我刚刚参与了一系列关于艺术与同理心的研究，但我们研究的不是视觉艺术，尽管也可以研究。我一直在研究叙事艺术，包括故事和电影。要进行这样的研究，你需要做的是找一组人，将他们随机分配到一个故事中，以及一个内容相同但非叙事的形式中。然后测量他们的同理心，测量他们
We chose to have people read a book about undocumented immigrants. It's a memoir, so it's not fiction, but it is a story. It's called Dear America Notes on an Undocumented Immigrant by Jose Antonio Vargas. It's a very moving book, and it's about the suffering that people face. When they discover their undocumented, these are people that were brought over as children, not even knowing there was such a thing as documentation. And then they discover as adolescents, they're undocumented, they have to hide, they can't get driver's licenses, they can't apply for financial aid, they're stressed, et cetera.
对某件事的态度，在阅读前后进行测量。我们选择让人们阅读一本关于无证移民的书。这是一本回忆录，所以它不是虚构的，但它是一个故事。书名是《亲爱的美国：关于一名无证移民的笔记》，作者是何塞·安东尼奥·瓦尔加斯。这是一本非常感人的书，讲述了人们面临的苦难。当他们发现自己是无证件者时，这些人是作为儿童被带过来的，甚至不知道还有“证件”这种东西。然后他们在青春期发现自己没有证件，他们必须躲藏，不能考驾照，不能申请经济援助，他们感到压力重重，等等。
And we had the other group read factual information about the plight of undocumented immigrants, but it wasn't in story form. And we measured their attitudes about undocumented immigrants before and after reading, and then again one month later. And we did two studies, we're just now doing a third. But in the first study, we used undergraduate college students, who were already pretty sympathetic to undocumented immigrants. And we did find that the story, the memoir, moved their attitudes and the direction of empathy.
我们让另一组人阅读关于无证移民困境的事实信息，但不是以故事的形式。我们在阅读前后测量了他们对无证移民的态度，一个月后再次测量。我们做了两项研究，现在正在做第三项。但在第一项研究中，我们使用了本科大学生，他们本来就对无证移民相当同情。我们确实发现，这个故事，即回忆录，改变了他们的态度，并朝着同理心的方向发展。
And the nonfiction did not. So we said, okay, well, we took people that were already positive and we pushed them to be a bit more positive. Let's see what we could do with people who are starting out negative. So we did a study where we only enrolled people who identified themselves as conservative, because we know that there is a correlation between being conservative and being anti-immigrant. that has been shown factually, empirically. So in this study, people started out negative, and they moved to significantly more positive
而非虚构作品则没有。所以我们说，好吧，我们找了一些本来就持积极态度的人，并推动他们变得更积极一些。让我们看看对于那些一开始持消极态度的人，我们能做些什么。因此，我们进行了一项研究，只招募了那些自认为是保守派的人，因为我们知道保守派与反移民之间存在相关性。这已被事实和经验证明。所以在这项研究中，人们一开始持消极态度，但他们转变为明显更积极的态度
if they were in the memoir group. But we're now doing... So I think that was a very good piece of evidence. I was actually very skeptical, because I think it's very easy to say, oh, art makes you empathetic, fiction makes you empathetic. It's very hard to actually prove those things.
如果他们属于回忆录组的话。但我们现在正在做……所以我认为那是一个非常好的证据。我实际上非常怀疑，因为我认为很容易说，哦，艺术让你有同理心，小说让你有同理心。要真正证明这些事情是非常困难的。
You feel empathetic, because you feel you're empathizing with the characters, But that doesn't mean you're going to change how you are once you close the book or turn off the movie. So I was surprised at our findings. We're now doing a third study to see if we really, really get this effect because we had a problem in our first two studies. The memoir and the factual text were not the same length. The factual text was much shorter because we didn't think we could get people to read a 200-page factual text. So now what we've done is we've shortened the memoir.
你感到有同理心，因为你觉得你在与角色产生共鸣，但这并不意味着当你合上书或关掉电影后，你会改变你的行为方式。所以我对我们的发现感到惊讶。我们现在正在进行第三项研究，看看我们是否真的能得到这种效果，因为我们在前两项研究中遇到了一个问题。回忆录和事实文本的长度不一致。事实文本短得多，因为我们认为我们无法让人们阅读200页的事实文本。所以现在我们缩短了回忆录。
We had excerpted the memoir to 20 pages and we've got 20. 20 pages of highly readable media text about undocumented immigrants. So we'll see if we still get the effect. Huh. So that's interesting, an area where you're working. What are some of the other unanswered questions out there that you would like to see answered? Well, one question I would really like to see answered is what kind of, what are the early signs in artistic giftedness and visual art giftedness that predict actually becoming an artist
我们将回忆录摘录为20页，并且我们有20页关于无证移民的高度可读的媒体文本。所以我们将看看我们是否仍然能得到这种效果。嗯。这很有趣，这是你正在研究的一个领域。还有哪些你希望看到答案的未解之谜？嗯，我非常希望看到答案的一个问题是，艺术天赋和视觉艺术天赋的早期迹象是什么，这些迹象能预测一个人是否真的会成为一名艺术家
as an adult, a creative artist? because most gifted kids do not go on in their area, no matter how precocious, most of them do not go on as adults to become great creators in that area. So a mathematically gifted child, a very child prodigy in math, is not necessarily going to become a giant in math. They might become an accountant or a math professor, not that there's anything wrong with that. It's just, and they might even drop out of their field of math. So I'm interested in what are the different predictors that lead a child. prodigy to go on in visual art. And it can't just be that they're good at drawing realistically, because the art world today doesn't even value that. So one of the prodigies I studied is still
成年后成为一名创造性的艺术家？因为大多数有天赋的孩子并没有在他们的领域继续发展，无论他们多么早熟，大多数人在成年后并没有成为该领域的伟大创造者。所以一个有数学天赋的孩子，一个数学神童，并不一定会成为数学界的巨人。他们可能会成为会计师或数学教授，这并没有什么错。只是，他们甚至可能放弃数学领域。所以我感兴趣的是，是什么不同的预测因素导致一个神童在视觉艺术领域继续发展。这不可能仅仅是因为他们擅长写实绘画，因为今天的艺术界甚至不重视这一点。所以我研究的神童之一仍然
drawing highly realistically as an adult, and he's teaching art somewhere. But his art is never going to be considered great, I'm sure, because it's just totally realistic, and we've had that. So what are the factors you might look at? I mean, is it parental encouragement or mentorship? What are the factors? Right. So one of the factors. is being really interested in the art world. And I'm interested in which kids, which of these prodigies, and that could be an effective parent too, but which of these prodigies actually want to look at what artists have done?
成年后还在画高度写实的作品，并且在某处教艺术。但我敢肯定，他的艺术永远不会被认为是伟大的，因为它完全是写实的，我们已经见过这种作品了。那么你可能会关注哪些因素呢？我的意思是，是父母的鼓励还是导师的指导？有哪些因素？对。所以其中一个因素是真正对艺术界感兴趣。我感兴趣的是哪些孩子，哪些神童，这可能也与父母的影响有关，但哪些神童真的想看看艺术家们做了什么？
Because they then understand that they're part of a larger community of artists. And I think another thing that's been speculated about what predicts which prodigies go on to be creators is that they have a certain person they're not satisfied with the status quo. They want to change things. And so after they master an adult invented field like math or realistic drawing, they then want to shake things up and explore and experiment and try new things. And if somebody wants to do that, I think they're much more likely to go on to be a creator in their field. So those are two aspects that I think might predict, making the leap from a prodigy to a creator in the visual art, in the visual arts.
因为他们随后会明白他们是一个更大的艺术家社区的一部分。我认为关于预测哪些神童会成为创造者的另一个猜测是，他们有一种不满足于现状的特质。他们想要改变事物。因此，在他们掌握了像数学或写实绘画这样由成人发明的领域后，他们想要打破常规，探索、实验并尝试新事物。如果有人想这样做，我认为他们更有可能在自己的领域成为创造者。所以这是我认为可能预测从神童到视觉艺术领域创造者跨越的两个方面。
So that's one thing I would like to look at. I also don't think we've at all nailed this thing about empathy and art. William James once said that he worried about the Russian lady sitting in the theater, weeping over the plight of the characters on stage while her coachman was outside freezing. And I think that says a lot. It means that we can feel extremely empathetic towards characters and fiction, but remain unchanged as soon as we step out of the fictional world. It's almost as if we've paid our empathy dues, and now we can go back to being as hard-hearted as we wanted. And I, it feels good to say art makes us empathetic. It's a feel-good statement. I would like it to be true. But I think we need a lot more work in that area than my, than what we have
所以这是我想研究的一件事。我也不认为我们已经完全弄清楚了同理心和艺术之间的关系。威廉·詹姆斯曾经说过，他担心那位坐在剧院里为舞台上角色的困境而哭泣的俄罗斯女士，而她的车夫却在外面冻得发抖。我认为这说明了很多问题。这意味着我们可以对虚构的角色感到极大的同理心，但一旦我们走出虚构的世界，我们却依然如故。这几乎就像我们已经支付了同理心的费用，现在我们可以回到我们想要的那种铁石心肠的状态。而且，说艺术让我们有同理心感觉很好。这是一个让人感觉良好的陈述。我希望它是真的。但我认为我们需要在该领域做更多的工作，而不是我们目前所拥有的
so far in fiction. And we don't have this kind of study at all with music or with visual art. Well, Dr. Winter, this has been fascinating. I really appreciate you're taking the time today to talk to us. Thank you. Thank you very much for having me, Kim. It's been a pleasure. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www.combeatingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you're listening on Apple, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org.
到目前为止在小说方面的研究。我们根本没有对音乐或视觉艺术进行过这种研究。好吧，温特博士，这太令人着迷了。我非常感谢你今天抽出时间与我们交谈。谢谢。非常感谢你的邀请，金。很高兴能参加。你可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Stitcher 或你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果你在 Apple 上收听，请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。
Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condihan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪汉。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。